bonsoir et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
semaine du 7 8 l'aktu le journal de la
rédaction sur téléphiles 78 voici les
titres qui seront développés ce soir
trois ministres dont l'yvelinois benoît
hamon à la verrière aujourd'hui dans les
locaux de la mgen l'enjeu le recrutement
de 1500 emplois d'avenir par les
établissements hospitaliers le site
saint quentinois
elle vient d'ailleurs d'embaucher 6
nouveaux brancardier sous ce statut elle
dès cette semaine une charte de la
laïcité sera affichée dans les écoles
publiques le ministre de l'éducation
entend rappeler ainsi les valeurs de la
république et puis un coup d'état
mitigé à maurepas le festival n'a attiré
que quelques 2500 visiteurs en
programmant fm sergent garcia ou encore
jennifer ce week end pour débuter cette
édition je vous propose l'image du
joueur vous en avez l'habitude l'image
de ce 9 septembre et ses policiers qui
aujourd'hui ne verbaliser pas elle les
auteurs d'infractions légères à la
circulation et au stationnement
opération nationale ici organisé à
versailles une action menée à l'appel du
syndicat alliance afin de contester le
projet de réforme des retraites et le
projet de réforme pénale des faux pv
expliquant leurs revendications ont
aussi été distribués dans le détail il
souhaite une meilleure prise en compte
de la pénibilité de leur métier est
aussi coté justice que l'incarcération
devienne la règle le syndicat alliance
parle de laxisme et de hausse probable
de la délinquance avec cette réforme on
écoute l'un des représentants du
syndicat à propos de cette opération
inédite c'est pas quelque chose de
courant et c'est surtout que c'est une
autre façon de faire qu'une
traditionnelle manifestation de rue
c'est une façon pour nous de mobiliser
nos collègues mais aussi d'attirer et
d'avoir la sympathie de la population
pour nous soutenir et pour ceux pour
soutenir sa police nationale voilà pour
ces quelques précisions demain mardi
opération plus traditionnel avec la
journée nationale de mobilisation une
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites nous y reviendrons dans notre
prochaine édition
elle les invités de cette édition du 9
septembre jean ignace de bail ou bonsoir
vous êtes directeur de la mgen à la
verrière et puis également le docteur
fabien jour bonsoir à vous le directeur
médical du site hospitalier juin
la verrière ce matin vous avez reçu la
visite non pas d'un mais de trois
ministres marisol touraine la ministre
des affaires sociales de la santé
michèle delaunay ministre déléguée aux
personnes âgées à l'autonomie et puis
également 2 benoît hamon ministre
délégué à l'économie sociale et
solidaire un déplacement pour signer une
convention d'engagement pour le
recrutement de 1500 emplois d'avenir par
les adhérents à la fédération des
établissements hospitaliers et des aides
à la personne privés non lucratifs on va
préciser tout ça avec vous dans un
instant auparavant
regardez ce reportage il est signé clair
qu'en billets et jonathan vilma ensuite
nous allons échanger autour de cette
table 1500 emplois d'avenir d'ici fin
c'est ce que promet la fée ap la
fédération regroupant les organismes
sociaux médicaux privés à but non
lucratif pour marquer cet engagement
trois ministres se sont rendus à la
verrière dans une unité de soins
gériatriques ici six jeunes ont été
recrutés comme brancardier
beaucoup ont enchaîné des petits boulots
avant de s'engager dans le milieu
médical
avec ces contrats d'avenir ils
obtiennent un cdd de 30 mois et une
formation sans change que jean marc murs
plus sur oreuse que je gerbe cependant
toutes les outrances et bien sûr pour le
joli l'état s'engage de son côté à
financer une partie des salaires à
hauteur de 75% du smic ainsi que la
formation pour la fée ap cr facilite
grandement le recrutement
en tous les cas c'est une incitation
extrêmement forte et qui doivent qui
fait qu' on ne peut pas passer à côté
mais je ne sais pas répondre à la
question de savoir si
on aurait employeurs n'aurait
probablement employés - l'objectif reste
cependant de reconduire ses nouvelles
recrues
une fois formés en cdi dans les yvelines
on comptabiliserait aujourd'hui près de
700 emplois d'avenir le gouvernement
espère atteindre les 100 mille embauches
en france d'ici la fin de l'année
signature donc ce matin de cette
convention vous l'avez entendu et 500
emplois d'avenir pour le secteur de la
santé déjà tease dans votre
établissement à la mgen ce sont des
brancardiers
comment se passe leur encadrement
qu'elle est spécifiquement leur travail
est ce qu'il ya un moment aussi dédié à
la formation
oui si brancardier depuis un an pour
certains depuis quelques jours pour les
deux derniers arrivés ils sont chacun un
tuteur qui les accompagnent au quotidien
dans leurs difficultés éventuelles et
puis bien évidemment des formations
puisque l'établissement s'engage par le
biais de ce ces contrats à former les
jeunes qui sont recrutés et dans le
domaine médical aussi s'avérer dangereux
mais moi aussi tout de même peut-être
une fibre aussi pour ce genre de
profession peut-être demandé au docteur
sur ce plateau aussi comment ça se passe
sur cet encadrement et sur cette fibre
et ce qu'ils n'ont est-ce qu'ils ne
l'ont pas est-ce qu'on peut l'occulter
aussi d'abord les recrutements de
de ces personnels se fait par des
soignants on
par la direction des soins qui ont
l'habitude de recruter des personnels
soignants qu'ils ont quand même des
critères à ce niveau là autour du rire
et du savoir-vivre et l'humanité de
de ces jeunes qu'ils recherchaient
deuxièmement comme le disait monsieur de
bayou il ya une formation spécifique qui
va être réalisé en tant que grand cardié
mais au delà de la formation géré
classique au sein même de
l'établissement
donc ils sont encadrés par des tuteurs
par l'amp les brancardiers sont bons les
cipan en carnet ont deux tuteurs une
étude dont deux tutrice une tutrice qui
est une kinésithérapeute du fait de la
nécessité de devoir mobiliser des
personnes âgées et savoir comment les
disposer sur sur une chaise roulante ou
sur un chariot et c est une autre
tutrice qui est une cadre de soins donc
l'habitude bien sûr de la gestion du
personnel dans les unités de soins
donc si brancardiers qui sont recrutés
sous ce statut là en tout dans
l'ensemble des établissements dont vous
faites partie on a entendu tout à
l'heure le président de l'afe ap
il y en a mille six cent des
établissements comme ça il y aura mille
cinq cents emplois c'est à dire que pour
vous il y en aura plus ça y est c'est
cissé sait pas plus
un an non pas du tout au contraire
n'étaient pas des fautes à part
établissements adhérents
non non non alors les 1600 c'est dans
l'établissement de la fe à plat une gêne
de son côté a signé une convention en
novembre 2012
sur le même sujet on s'était engagé en
trente centres ans dans le groupe
certains dans les centres de services
donc plutôt sur le métier de régime de
gestion du régime de sécurité sociale
dans les établissements il n'y a pas de
quotas pour ce qui nous concerne nous
avons nous avions besoin de brancardiers
nous en aurons besoin demain on a
d'autres besoins je pense en ce moment à
un recrutement en cours pour quelqu'un
dans l'animation on va continuer mais ce
sera avec ce statut
attention le prix pour le début autour
des buts et oui vous nous disiez vous
aviez besoin de brocarder vous ne les
avez pas recruter avant la création de
ce statut de ces emplois d'avenir ça
veut dire que vous n'aviez pas les
moyens de les recruter
exactement ce qu'on l'a on entendu dans
le reportage est un avantage financière
ça ne coûte rien au fait at -
l'établissement une prise en charge 75 %
par l'état et il faut préciser que dans
les yvelines
la délégation territoriale de la rs
prend en charge 2 25% restants donc
effectivement on pourrait dire que ça ne
coûte rien hormis les frais de formation
c'est un cdd d'une trentaine de mois
trois ans avec cette formation
l'entendue à l'issue du cdd
m quoi l'issue du cdd et à la base n'ont
pas de formation justement le but c'est
de leur mettre le pied à l'étrier mais
aussi peut-être de les garder
à l'issue du cdd à l'issue des 36 mois
nous aurons toujours besoin de
brancardiers j'entends bien faire le
maximum pour les garder sur place
souligne les brancardiers ou d'autres
qu'on évoque la des brancardiers mais
par exemple sur l'établissement on est
en recherche constante d'aide-soignante
donc en même temps on est dans une
difficulté on dit qu'il ya pas de
l'emploi et en même temps il ya des
emplois maintenant il faut arriver à
accompagner ces jeunes parce qu'il faut
un minimum de formation pour pouvoir
accéder quand même un des métiers de la
santé qui qui nécessite quand même un
certain bagage
on va écouter justement la ministre la
ministre en charge de ce dossier de la
santé marisol touraine elle va nous
expliquer qu'il ya de l'emploi quand
vous venez de nous le dire dans ce
secteur il y à plus de 50000 emplois
d'avenir d'ores et déjà assignés 52000
fin août et fin juillet il y avait onze
mille emplois d'avenir signée dans les
trois secteurs de la santé du
médico-social et du social c'est donc
une part très significative qui
représente même près du tiers des
emplois signer si l'on exclut
l'éducation nationale donc on voit qu'il
ya une mobilisation forte des acteurs de
la santé
il y a aussi des besoins forts dans le
domaine de la santé dans le seul domaine
social il y a des besoins forts il ya ce
coup de pouce de l'état avec ses
créations d'emplois d'avenir est ce que
pour autant vous allez réussir à les
trouver tous ces jeunes j'espère qu'on
fera tout ce qu'il faut pour n'y a pas
de difficulté justement bien
suffisamment de candidats il ya
suffisamment de candidats pour les deux
derniers nous avons recruté il y avait
une dizaine de candidats donc le la
difficulté était plutôt de faire le
choix parmi tous les candidats a
peut-être préciser un vous appartenez à
la fée ap la fédération des
établissements hospitaliers et d'aidé à
la personne privés non lucratifs
combien d'établissements quel est le
rôle un petit peu de cette fédération
grosso modo on pourrait dire qu'en
france il y a trois secteurs le secteur
public qui représente 50 % des
établissements le secteur privé
commercial ou lucratif qui représente 40
% et entre les deux le petit secteur du
privé non lucratif donc 10 % des
établissements restants
ça représente donc plus de 200 mille
salariés en france
que dire de plus les lettres tous les
établissements alors nous sommes des
établissements de jeu les trente trois
établissements de l'aisne jeunes sont
adhérents à la ferme et sur le site de
la verrière dans quels domaines les
spécifications exigées sur le site de la
verrière deux établissements un
établissement de santé mentale dans
lequel nous étions ce matin est un
établissement qui est à 500 mètres de là
dans la médecine et des soins de suite
en gériatrie avec un ehpad également est
un projet qui est assez connue
maintenant sur le territoire qui est un
projet de reconstruction totale des deux
établissements à très court terme
puisque d'ici 4-5 ans on devait avoir
fait l'essentiel des travaux ont évoqué
ce dossier des travaux dans quelques
instants juste pour en terminer avec
cette visite ce matin des trois
ministres pourquoi ont-ils fait le choix
de votre établissement
l'établissement modèle vous avez déjà
six emplois d'avenir on établissement
modèle oui certainement parce qu'elle
méritait certainement la faire péter à
l'initiative de cette demande de
signature
il a fait rechercher un établissement
adhérents qui avaient déjà effectivement
des contrats les gens embauchés
voilà pourquoi tout le monde est venu à
la verrière et nous en sommes très
contents
en tant que professionnels de la santé
en tant que médecin docteur jean qui est
sur ce plateau ces emplois d'avenir
c'est un plus pour le secteur vous êtes
satisfait que le gouvernement se penche
sur cette question là bien sûr c'est un
plus d'abord sont dans le domaine de la
santé bien sûr mais déjà c'est une offre
pour les jeunes concernant le travail et
gérer et en se positionnant du côté
soignants du monde sanitaire
demain on va voir un manque d'effectif
monumental dans le monde de la santé
et il est indispensable qu'on accompagne
cette nouvelle génération dans ces
métiers de la santé qui peuvent
apprendre bien sûr dans des écoles ou
dans les universités mais je crois
qu'elle sera prête surtout sur le
terrain donc accompagner des jeunes qui
comme dans le cas des emplois à venir
qui n'ont pas obligatoirement une
formation au départ mais qui viennent
apprendre sur le terrain le contact avec
les patients et les soignants
c'est essentiel donc ils n'emploient à
venir c'est un
initiative que vous saluer en tout cas
en tout à fait rationnel et la sent tout
à fait tout à fait dans un contexte où
je crois que le monde de la santé le
sanitaire médico-social est un peu
oubliée actuellement comme qui dirait un
lieu de gérer de travail d'emploi
important pour les dizaines et dizaines
d'années à venir d'autant plus avec le
vieillissement de la population et où la
pratique de la dépendance
alors vous l'avez évoqué pour conclure
ses travaux ils vont débuter 2014
toujours ce sentier d'envergure fin 2004
2014 mais on commence en de phoenix qui
s'appelle la préprogrammation et nous
allons commencer au mois d'octobre la
programmation c'est à dire le travail
avec les équipes médicales les équipes
soignantes toutes les équipes de terrain
pour bien déterminer le cahier des
charges de notre futur établissement
on devrait accueillir entre 450 et 500
vies sur le site actuel de l'institut
dans cette rude hiver
c'est donc une refondation complète du
site à quoi ressemblera la même semaine
sur la verrière en 2017 2018 elle sera
recentré donc sur le sur l'institut
marcel-rivière avec une ouverture que
nous espérons plus tourner sur la
verrière les terrains denis forestier
pour l'instant aucune décision n'est
prise mais le notre volonté est temps de
s'inscrire pleinement sur le territoire
nous travaillons en bonne collaboration
avec la mairie de la verrière qui est en
train de travailler sur son pays à l'ue
son plan local d'urbanisme et on sait
que nos terrains sont intéressant à plus
d'un titre
une partie des terrains qui seront qui
termine finalement seront ouvertes pour
le public r absolument absolument et
très prochainement nous aurons le parc
de
l'institut marcel rivière à la
population de la verrière merci à vous
deux merci d'être venu sur ce plateau le
plateau du 7-8 seule lecture je rappelle
que ce matin signature d'une convention
entre l'état les établissements affiliés
à la fédération des établissements
hospitaliers et d'aidé à la personne
privés non lucratifs dont l'âme humaine
fait partie à la clé 1500 emplois
d'avenir il y en a déjà site sur 6 sur
votre site à la verrière nous
poursuivons ce journal avec le projet
d'établissement d'hébergement des
personnes âgées dépendantes un ehpad à
montigny le bretonneux projet enfin
validé l' agence régionale régionale de
santé et le conseil général des yvelines
ont tranché
l'ouverture se fera en 2016 dans le parc
du château de la couldre là où se
trouvait auparavant le siège de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il disposera de 80 lits d'hébergement
permanent de quatre lits d'hébergement
temporaire est un pôle d'activités et de
soins adaptés de 14 places pour les
personnes atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer
elle encourt une nouvelle résidence pour
les étudiants ont ouverte offrant 161
logement cette résidence a été
construite dans les locaux de l'ancien
immeuble de bureaux le capitole
résidences gérées par le crous qui
augmente au total sa capacité d'offre de
800 places supplémentaires pour cette
rentrée dans le département catherine
zonato et patrick jacques de dixmude
elle porte le nom d'un prix nobel de la
paix rené cassin c'est donc le nom de la
nouvelle résidence étudiante qui vient
d'ouvrir à l encours 161 logement de 16
à 25 mètres carrés comprenant
kitchenette et salle de bain même à dix
chambres pouvant recevoir les couples le
tout géré par le crous avec un loyer
mensuel pour un étudiant boursier
compris entre 220 et 230 euros
on loge effectivement priorité des
étudiants boursiers sur critères sociaux
mais pas seulement on peut répondre aux
besoins aussi en accueil international
avec des étudiants qui viennent en
mobilité auprès de l'université de
versailles saint quentin ou des écoles
qui réserve effectivement et des
logements pour ses étudiants on attend
justement l'arrivée des étudiants sous
convention des changes pour stabiliser
l'offre qui a été réservé par rapport à
ce qui va réellement arrivé au niveau de
l'université
et puis on a des listes d'attendre une
résidence aux couleurs vives et aux
matériaux nobles qui fait facilement
oublier l'immeuble de bureaux le
capitole qui abritait les locaux
transformés des bureaux en logements
s'est encore rares mais cela tend à se
développer
les bureaux en logements c'est pas
courant ça se fait de plus en plus parce
qu'il ya une vraie volonté effectivement
de la part de nos gouvernants quel qu'il
soit on va dire d'améliorer l'offre de
logements est actuellement par exemple
nous avons une opération surveille
malmaison où nous transformons des
bureaux en logements familiaux
donc ça se fait de plus en plus ça a été
une opération assez compliqué puisque
effectivement les bâtiments qui sont
fins fait pour accueillir des bureaux
n'ont pas les mêmes tramelan
les mêmes contraintes structurelles que
peuvent avoir des bâtiments de logements
et notamment des résidences pour
étudiants
donc ça a été la principale difficulté
la résidence étudiante rené cassin la 7e
gérés par le crous sur le secteur de
versailles saint quentin le crous ne
s'arrête pas en si bon chemin et ouvre
pour cette rentrée 2013 six nouvelles
résidences et offre ainsi 800 places
d'hébergement supplémentaires dans le
département toutefois la demande est
déjà saturé il faut donc continuer à
construire mais depuis que les
résidences étudiantes font partie du
quota de logement social à respecter
dans une commune elle trouve de mieux en
mieux leur place dans les politiques
locales d'habitants vincent peillon a
dévoilé sa charte pour la laïcité à
l'école à un texte qui sera affiché à
l'entrée de chacun des établissements
scolaires publics le ministre entend
rappeler les valeurs de la république et
les expliquer parmi les différents
articles la laïcité assure aux élèves
l'accès à une culture commune et
partagée ou encore le port de signes ou
tenues par lesquels les élèves
manifestent ostensiblement une
appartenance religieuse est interdite ce
qui nous amène à notre question du jour
une telle charte à quoi peut-elle servir
peut-elle être efficace surtout voici
vos réponses avec ce micro-trottoir
s'apprêter à vue aux enfants de dates
libres dans la tête de s'adapter mais un
e hôte aussi pour une égalité que tous
les enfants
voilà il n'y a pas de caractère
discriminatoire entre eux dans le choix
des vêtements dans le choix de la langue
dans le choix et qui dit pas de
d'imposition à la meilleure manière de
désamorcer la bombe
justement entre les communautés quelles
qu'elles soient et d'état cdh affiché sa
neutralité essayer de réguler les
éventuels problèmes qui peuvent qui peut
y avoir dans les écoles et des collèges
sur les phénomènes de laïcité surtout
les phénomènes de religion à côté conte
qui sont directement liés
autre sujet les braqueurs du quick de
coignières la semaine dernière voulait
financer un éventuel départ pour la
syrie pour mener le djihad interpellé
jeudi quatre hommes âgés de 23 à 33 ans
membres présumés d'une cellule islamiste
radicale
comptez utiliser les 3000 euros du butin
pour rejoindre les quelques 200 français
qui combattent déjà le régime de bachar
el-assad en syrie est la garde à vue des
quatre hommes se poursuit lors du
braquage qui s'est déroulée le 4
septembre et clients et personnel avait
été menacé avec deux armes de poing qui
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
serait factice avant de revenir sur le
festival coup d'état c'est de la culture
festival qui se déroulait ce week end à
maurepas une information concernant le
réseau 4g censé remplacer l'actuelle 3g
sur nos portables dans les prochaines
années orange s'est lancé ce matin dans
la bataille avec la présentation du
déploiement sur paris et sur l'île de
france
pas d'emballement la seule ville des
yvelines concerné pour l'instant vélizy
et pour les riverains cela peut
entraîner quelques perturbations un
numéro qui s'est affichée qui vous
permettra d'en savoir plus et de trouver
une solution si vous êtes concerné ce
week end à maurepas le festival pop rock
coup d'état deuxième édition valeur
montante et artistes confirmés étaient
présents mais finalement moins de
visiteurs qu'attend du retour néanmoins
sur l'ambiance rock de ce festival
c'était vendredi soir avec à la fiche
eiffel sergent garcia ou encore poni
hoax aurélia de bissy et jonathan vilma
eiffel sergent garcia jenifer ou encore
axelle red
voilà quelques uns des artistes qui
étaient sur la scène du festival pop
rock coup d'état vendredi et samedi à
maurepas
malgré une météo un peu capricieuse en
deux jours le festival a accueilli plus
de 2500 personnes
la sergent garcia c'est pour lui ah
ouais et l'ambiance et parce qu'on
habite à côté et que c'est sympa qu'un
petit festival comme ça donc je veux
arrêter
si beau j'aime bien les festivals de
rock en général du côté des artistes la
scène du coup d'état est l'occasion de
présenter leur dernier album venus tout
droit de bordeaux
le groupe rock eiffel poursuit sa
tournée avec foule monstre leur
cinquième album je pense soit orange ou
une heure et quart qu'on va jouer après
14 15 titres voilà et qu'on va jouer
sûrement 8,8 et de nouvel album on a
fait des emprunts et musique on adore
celle du rap dans l'idée de cela mais on
ne peut pas de la musique rap mais on
emprunte et aussi on a vachement aiguisé
de santé et de book machine de boîtes à
rythme etc
je n'en ai jamais fait auparavant le
quintet parisien poni hoax revient avec
son troisième opus state of war il a été
réalisée très différemment on avait fait
des prises après on a on a travaillé à
la maison on a tous des trucs des
structures et on a beaucoup produit
derrière et là en fait on avait répété
même parfois jouer les morceaux en
concert avant d enregistrer donc on a
vraiment on a beaucoup moins travailler
après on a travaillé sur le moment que
pendant les prises et après en a moins
- travailler derrière et donc du coup
effectivement s'il est différent des
autres
sergent garcia créateur du célèbre salsa
muffin de retour sur les scènes
françaises après deux ans de tournée
internationale présente una y otra vez
savent album qu'on enregistrait qui est
sorti il ya deux ans maintenant on l'a
enregistré entre quatre pays la france
l'espagne cuba et la colombie avec une
grosse partie en colombie il ya 27
musiciens de sur cet album
dont dix musiciens colombiens de la
scène la nouvelle scène
colombienne c'est un album qui est un
groupe un petit peu de beaucoup d'époque
de sergent garcia avec toujours cet axe
entre la musique latine et la musique
jamaïcaine le reggae la salsa toujours
présent mais avec une couleur vachement
colombienne on pourrait même dire afro
colombienne avec des morceaux de cumbia
avec des morceaux de musique afro
colombiennes inspiré du culte et rythmes
du pacifique c'est un pays la colombie
qui a une richesse culturelle énorme qui
a des rythmes indigènes qui a des
rythmes afro qui a sept comptes via qui
est extraordinaire pour faire danser les
gens
et du coup il ya un petit peu de toute
cette ambiance là c'est le sergent
garcia en colombie quoi avis aux
amateurs sergent garcia sortira fin
octobre une anthologie de 2006 2010
double dvd et sera au bataclan 24
janvier prochain
là
et lors de ce festival une opération de
prévention et de sécurité routière a été
mené l'association voiture et nous
proposer aux conducteurs qui le
souhaitaient de s'engager rester sobre
lors de la soirée surtout à déposer
leurs clés aux stands
en échange des boissons sans alcool bien
évidemment et des lots étaient offerts
comme nous l'expliquent est l'un des
animateurs de prévention au micro
d'aurélia débit si l'objectif de ce soir
en fait c'est faire de la prévention et
la sécurité routière les conducteurs qui
le souhaitent peuvent déposer leur
plaire d'autres stands en arrivant et on
leur offre déjà de boissons soft à ce
moment là en fait le principe c'est
quand ils repartent en effet souffler
dans l'éthylotest
pour être certain qu'ils ne dépassent
pas le tour
solide qui exerçant que
j'en parlais et donc pas ce qu'on leur
offre des cadeaux
si le test était donc à ce moment-là on
trouve toujours des solutions soit on
fait patienter un peu les personnes ci
n'ont pas trop sinon et on trouve des
solutions avec des amis
la famille
pour les rares et tout en faisant
souffler bien sûr non vérifiables et des
remplaçants entre guillemets au permis
aussi samedi et dimanche 1er week-end
traditionnels pour faire son choix
d'activités associatives sportives ou
bien culturel à montigny le bretonneux
le forum existe depuis maintenant 25 ans
l'occasion tout de même de découvrir de
nouvelles activités comme le yoga du
rire le premier club du genre vient
d'ouvrir sur la commune il en existe
déjà un voisins le bretonneux et un
autre à versailles tout le monde peut
participer quel que soit son âge
les séances qui vont débuter à compter
du mois d'octobre au club le village
deux séances par mois cotisation
annuelle 95 euros un des membres de
l'association nous explique les
principes de la rigologie vous allez
voir c'est très sérieux
le yoga du rire est un ensemble
d'exercices qui combine la respiration
et le rire ça vient aux dindes
c'est un docteur indien un généraliste
qui s'appelle au docteur madan kataria
qui à qui on a demandé de rédiger une
synthèse sur les bienfaits du rire sur
la santé il s'est dit il ya autant de
bienfaits dans content rires rire sans
raison
des neurologues comme le docteur henri
rubinstein ont démontré qu'il y avait
trois axes sourire un axe respiratoires
on respire comte henry healy à un axe
musculaire ça permet de détendre tous
les muscles ça permet de travailler
aussi tous les muscles depuis de tout
petits muscles du visage jusqu'à la
musculature abdominale et le troisième
axe est un axe neurologique à les
médecins ont démontré que le corps
produisait de l'endorphine une hormone
ont contre la douleur
le rire est très bon pour la digestion
c'est très bon pour le sommeil c'est
très bon pour les gens qui ont de
l'asthme
et puis si vous avez manqué le forum des
associations ce week end vous pouvez
encore vous rattraper le week end
prochain deux forums l'un à magny les
hameaux et puis l'autre à guyancourt a
noté qu à guyancourt yvan le bolloc'h
donnera un concert gratuit le 14
septembre donc samedi à l'issue de à
l'après midi un mot de sport pour
terminer à présent ce journal ce week
end le stade du bout du cloud à maurepas
accueillez une rencontre internationale
de rugby entre les -19 ans du stade
français et la belgique sur le banc de
touche parisien rémy mathias ludovic
guillaume ont remplacé sébastien année
pour l'instant ils apprennent à
connaître leur nouvelle effective sur ce
dernier match de préparation avant
l'ouverture du championnat l'intensité
physique était tout de même bien
présente
les stadistes longtemps porté il
s'impose 31-27 les entraîneurs parisiens
qui attendent la fin des matches aller
pour se fixer un objectif de fin de
saison pour tout savoir sur le sport
rendez vous lundi 18h30 19h30 et 23h
pour le 7-8 sport avec anthony rech
également à retrouver en replay dès le
lendemain matin mardi matin sur notre
site internet
et bien sûr à partager sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est la fin de cette édition du
journal du 9 septembre je vous retrouve
demain pour l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale passé une excellente soirée sur
téléphiles